Something kind of fun happened this morning. My channel rolled over all 7's 7, 777,777
I was not planning to make a video at all today today's supposed to be my day off,
but I have something I want to show you.
All of my countertops for the first time in years are almost completely clutter-free.
This little table over here has had stuff sitting on
It ever since I moved it down here from four years ago
And this entire area has been crammed packed with clutter ever since we finished the kitchen down here
This is the only clutter. I have left it will probably all be cleaned up in the next couple of weeks.
So let's talk for a minute about the rice experiment from yesterday's video. The comments on that video are amazing
So let me just start off by saying no, I wasn't high when I film that video it was not an april
Fool's prank it was not a social experiment although the kind of reaction to God might make it worthy of one it was not promoting
Pseudosciences and it was not scientifically conclusive, but I like you guys
And I really care about what you think so when there's such a strong reaction like there wasn't a video yesterday
I feel like I have an obligation to give you the rest of the story.
First of all everything I said in the video was true
We did come across a book that people told the street like you most likely we were a little bit skeptical
But we thought we just read the book and see what I had to say, my wife
And I both read it it seemed interesting enough although. We weren't grasping on the concepts as truth instead
We thought it might be worth just having some fun and putting it to the test and see what happened
we'd seen on the internet the hundreds of people had tried taking cooked rice and putting them in different jars and
Labeling them and speaking to them so for a fun family
Activity we decided to get the kids involved and we tried that ourselves now. This is about five years ago
We just moved in our new house
I just started producing my king of random videos things got crazy busy, my wife let me know that for about a month
She did try to keep up with the experiment by having the kids talk to the jars in the morning before school
But with the craziness of life they eventually just got brushed aside,
Tucked on the shelf and completely forgot about and that right there was pretty much the end of the story until about six months later
We had some people visiting and they asked us what these jars were on the shelf and at that time we noticed they were changing
Color which we found was interesting. We said they've changed colors and interestingly enough
They'd change colors to kind of match the labeling on the jars now [likee] we didn't draw any conclusions
We just thought it was interesting and then forgot about them for about number four and a half years two weeks ago
I was running around my basement cleaning up everything that I could possibly clean up donate to charity throwing in the garbage and
Decluttering when I came across these jars
I thought it'd be fun just to do a quick video and show you the results of the experiment that we tried
I saw so many comments from people concerned that this wasn't followed through the scientific process there should have been more
Samples the jars should have been sterilized there should have been in control guys
did not see that coming if the result of this video inspire other people to try the results for themselves and
Everybody comes back with the same results
Then maybe this idea is worthy of a more scientific study until then it was just a simple family experiment
Non-Scientific never claimed it was, go back and watch my video, and you'll find that my words were chosen very carefully
But apparently they may not have been chosen carefully enough because a lot of you got triggered so on that note
I really hope I've been able to satisfy your concerns and put a little context behind the video obviously this wasn't an mit
Sponsored Scientific event they're just some kind of interesting results to a simple household experiment
I wanted to show you before I threw those jars away see in the next video
One last thing apparently I forgot to put the instagram link in the video where I mixed aluminum with brass
I still am giving away this master sword as well as all these metal alloys
So follow me on Instagram watch the stories in the next couple of days
I'll post a link on how you could apply to get them. See you there!
*Grant feeds his chickens*